the marvel cinematic universe only
scratches the surface when it comes to
mjolnir and stormbreaker
from their legendary origins to their
modern day enchantments
here's the truth behind thor's magical
weapons
you might already know this but the god
of thunder goes back way further than
their marvel comics debut in 1962
and so does his thunderous hammer
mjolnir got its origin story in the 13th
century prose edda
and like most norse mythology it
involves loki causing trouble
in this case he made a wager with a pair
of dwarves named brockier and
syndry you may know them from the 2018
game god of war
betting that they couldn't craft three
magical items that were the equal of
asgard's three greatest treasures
to rise to the challenge the
blacksmithing dwarves set about working
their forge and
despite loki's interference they crafted
a trio of treasures of their own
the most well-known of course was
mjolnir which turned out to be a pretty
good hammer
as powerful as it was mjolnir wasn't
thor's only piece of equipment in the
myths
to heft the incredibly heavy hammer a
problem that he had to face
long before marvel comics came along he
had to use another pair of magic items
the first was yarn gray pier a pair of
gauntlets known as the iron grippers
and the second was the meganjord a belt
that
doubled his already considerable
strength
we just got a load tony's old hulkbuster
armor prototype for cap's new shield
and the megan the meg the
thor's magic belt over the years marvel
has added or
adapted most of the mythological stories
behind the norse gods so it's not
surprising that both of those items
exist in the comics
however the megan george shows up rarely
on the page and to explain
why thor doesn't just wear it all the
time to double his strength
marvel's version according to thor
number 363
takes a pretty serious toll on the god
of thunder
marvel's version of mjolnir first
appeared in journey into mystery number
83
loaded up with a few interesting spells
to make for more exciting superhero
comic stories
the first of course was the familiar
enchantment by odin
that meant only the worthy could lift it
whosoever holds of this hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the powers
for the other though it seems like the
marvel masterminds may have been taking
some inspiration from a
lightning-powered hero who was a little
more recent than the pros etta
in the golden age of comics young billy
batson discovered a wizard in a cave
and said the magic word shazam to
transform with a thunderous blast into
captain marvel
the world's mightiest mortal he even
shared his power with a sidekick captain
marvel jr
whose secret identity was freddy freeman
a young man whose injured leg led him to
walk with a crutch
captain marvel stopped being published
in the 50s though he would eventually
come back as dc
shazam renamed for various legal reasons
fans might have found an interesting
alternative in 1962 though
marvel's version of thor was secretly
don blake
a doctor whose injured leg led him to
walk with a cane
he discovered a stout stick in a cave
and when he smacked it against the
ground
it turned into mjolnir and transformed
him with a thunderous blast into
thor the world's mightiest immortal
blake was then blessed with the strength
and power of thor
whether the marvel bullpen was actually
trying to recapture the magic of captain
marvel adventures by giving it some sort
of hot viking flavor is
certainly up for debate marvel's most
enduring addition to the mjolnir mythos
was the
enchantment that granted the power of
thor to those who were worthy of it
anyone who was worthy of it over the
years that's a list that has included a
surprising number of names
but the more notable examples include
steve rogers who first hefted the hammer
when he was operating as the captain
and later lifted it in his more familiar
identity of captain america
[Music]
assemble squirrel girl also got her
hands on the hammer and used it to stop
a misguided duplicate of herself who
couldn't lift the hammer from beating up
the marvel universe
the most eye-catching for crossover fans
however came at the climax of jla slash
avengers when superman charged into
battle wielding both captain america's
shield
and thor's hammer to save the day once
the battle was over however
superman found himself unable to lift it
leading thor to explain that odin
occasionally sees
fit to suspend the enchantment for
special occasions
in 1983 walt simonson took over as the
writer and artist of thor with number
337
he certainly brought in plenty of new
ideas the first big shift
ditching the thunder god's human
identity and making the new thor
a space horse okay it's slightly more
complicated than that
while investigating something in space
thor encounters an
alien warrior named beta ray bill in the
fight
thor loses his hammer and thanks to yet
another enchantment that required him to
keep in contact with it to maintain his
godly form
it turns back into blake's walking stick
a very frustrated bill grabs the stick
and
smacks it against the wall and readers
suddenly learned that this strange new
alien who definitely
seemed like a bad guy is every bit as
worthy as the guy with his name on the
cover
bill transformed into a new sci-fi thor
and was promptly whisked off to asgard
because odin's summoning spell was
looking for
thor not his son over the next few
issues bill has to battle to the death
against thor to determine who would be
the true god of thunder
which if we're being honest here is some
pretty rough parenting from odin the all
father
in the end though bill ended up saving
thor's life and proving himself to be a
good
and noble soul who just happened to look
like a giant skeletal horse
bill swore his loyalty to thor as his
oath brother and to reward his nobility
odin and etree the dwarf craft a new
hammer to be mjolnir's equal
stormbreaker it was every bit as strong
had the same enchantment about
worthiness
and the only big difference came in the
aesthetics
stormbreaker while made of the same uru
metal as mjolnir
appeared golden and had one flat hammer
head and an axe-like blade on the other
side
beta rebuild isn't the only strange
transformation that thor underwent
during walt simonsen's five-year run
at one point in the comics thor found
himself turned into a frog thanks to
let's say it all together now loki
while he was a frog he got caught in a
secret of nym style war between new york
city's frogs and the ravenous sewer rat
population that was being controlled by
a bad guy with low aspirations called
the piper the whole issue was built
around a struggle for thor to recover
his hammer
and when he did he struck it against the
ground and was thunderously transformed
into
a six foot six inch frog dressed like
thor
that's not the end of the frog's story
though while he was briefly amphibious
thor spent some time hanging out with a
frog named puddle gulp
who turned out was also a human
transformed into a frog
because that's the kind of thing that
happens when you're living in a universe
full of wizards
at one point however puddle gulp found a
shard of mjolnir that was chipped off by
one of thor's chariot pulling goats
puddle gulp lifted the shard struck it
against the ground
and became throgg the frog of thunder
unlike thor's time as the thunder frog
throg was still frog sized
with a tiny mule near to match this
hammer had all the abilities of the
regular version
and was thus given the extremely on the
nose name of fragile near
in 2014 thor came to the conclusion that
he was no longer worthy to wield mjolnir
and that the lack of confidence became a
self-fulfilling prophecy
while thor was being glum about this
turn of events and getting his left arm
chopped off by malekith the dark elf in
a pretty disastrous attempt at
hammerless crime fighting
jane foster believing that there must
always be a god of thunder to stand
against evil
hefted the hammer herself and became the
mighty thor
for the next three years jane was thor
but her tenure as the goddess offender
came to a crashing end when mjolnir
itself
was destroyed
it happened during a battle with the man
gog a creature that had come into being
in a past era when odin destroyed an
entire planet
and the pure hatred of its population
coalesced into a nearly unstoppable
monster
the key word there however is nearly
jane did end up stopping the man gog by
chaining him to mjolnir and hurling it
into the heart of the sun
as you may know from science the core of
the sun is roughly 10 000 degrees
fahrenheit and contains a constant
nuclear reaction
that turns out to be about the level of
force you need in order to destroy
a presumably unbreakable magic hammer
mjolnir was vaporized jane retired from
thoring
and the odin son once again took up his
heroic exploits using a series of
substitute hammers crafted by a dwarf
named
screwbeard sadly due to a shortage of
the mystical uru medal from which the
original mjornier had been crafted
none of the replacements were as good as
the genuine article
mjolnir may have been destroyed forever
but this is comics
it's only a matter of time before
everyone comes back from the dead
including hammers
in this case it happened during 2019's
war of the realms a
crossover event that shockingly was not
loki's fault
instead it's malekith again leading an
invasion of midgard or as we call it
earth from the united forces of the
other realms at the climax of the story
thor conjures up the god
tempest a storm so powerful that it
affects the sun itself
reforging mjolnir and sending it
crashing back to earth
the reborn mjolnir was pretty
recognizable as the original with the
exception of the handle
this incarnation had a handle made of
braided natural looking wood
presumably to bring it more into line
visually with the version of
stormbreaker that movie-going audiences
would have seen in avengers infinity war
and
end game it also retained the worthiness
enchantment
but thor now saw worthiness as a
struggle that we all face to be better
declaring himself along with his new
hammer to be the god of the unworthy
while they're easily the most notable
ones mjolnir and stormbreaker are
far from the only asgardian weapons to
show up on the page
most of the weapons that originated in
mythological sources are present in the
world of comics
like odin's spear gungner and heimdall's
magic sword
hoefund plus there's graham the sword of
the dragon slayer sigmund
levatine loki's sword whose name has the
amazing translation of
damage twig others however are unique to
the comics
before he proved himself worthy of
mjolnir thor used a fearsome axe named
yarn bjorn or iron bear is that a dragon
fan
it is my god
it's the same sort of alcohol dragonfang
which appeared on the screen in thor
ragnarok is the sword carried by
brunhilda the valkyrie
so named because it was literally carved
from a dragon's tooth
before he got his hands on a couple of
assault rifles scourge the executioner
was fond of using the blood axe to
behead his enemies and his violent name
is
pretty self-explanatory there are other
hammers too loki once crafted a mjolnir
like bludgeon named stormcaster that he
gave to the x-men's resident weather
controlling goddess
storm eric masterson briefly took on the
identity of thor while the actual god
was banished
and when the odin's son returned eric
became a hero named
thunderstrike wielding a magic mace of
the same name
most recently jane foster took up a
mystical asgardian artifact named
underyard the all weapon which can
transform into any weapon that jane
required in her new job as a valkyrie
oh and the asgardian name fittingly
enough for a weapon unique to the comics
page
it translates loosely to marvelous
weapon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you